you know this world is like people pass
judgment immediately and the thing about
me is people's judgments are usually
wrong while I was studying at Gill -
it's so important to just be like a
really great jazz musician I just really
wanted to dance but also I had this
other thing that I wanted to people
always ask me when I discovered I could
beat blogs as if I woke up one morning
was just like I but the reality is that
[Music]
this whole other community the stone
court intelligible Bellatrix making them
sounds cool Ramona so I met Bo when I
was naked playing the drums and a dust
bowl this massive hip-hop beat coming
from the kitchen and I was like I don't
know a minute that track sounds amazing
wanna see what it is it came down and it
was coming from her face so going to
that lot of the events you walk up
someone and be like they'll be like oh
yeah
everything about me is really mixed like
my blood this makes my family isn't it
my friends a twist my musical repertoire
I listen to as mix than my players most
head screwed on
in stories for the lad Bible realize
later on as I started to grow up and
that actually the reality is I can roll
in any of these circles I can go
wherever I want it's actually a real
like benefit that I am such a mix I'm
not actually here to find out how where
I fit into the world I have to hold true
to what is honestly me